Donald Trump got elected from your
Western Illinois are they still behind
them I think so i think what's going on
right now is a terrible distraction and
as you were just discussing Tom I think
you know there are going to be people
that are going to want to get to the
root of this thing and have you know a
real discectomy of what's going on you
you and I are that's fossils in the room
that remember 1973-74 Dan Rather's out
on Twitter last night respectfully
suggesting hmm this is a little bit
about Watergate to it are we at a point
yet or soon where your world of tax
reform investment infrastructure gets
derailed by the distraction of Russia or
whatever I think I think that's a very
legitimate point obviously we are very
excited within the business community
about the prospects of what we heard
corporate tax reduction repatriation
globalization well the market loves it
in mark and you're making money well not
as much as you but you're the expert in
the room Tom but again this is this is a
real bump in the road I think for all of
us right now and and it's not going to
done sound like it's going to go away
you and Kevin talking about this saying
really it's a big distraction q I don't
know how to look at this this is either
kind of the Watergate moment or this is
the institutions of America are working
yes the market seems to have a bet in
saying actually the institutions are
there and check and so he'll reflate the
economy and we'll all be fine are they
right in thinking that well look I think
it comes as a think on the whole the
checks and balances the u.s. system are
incredibly strong and so I think the
market is taking a view that the
reflection and to be honest the ain't
increasing global growth even before
Trump is actually now starting to spread
and I'm really struck by the optimism
the market we got an overreliance or
monetary policy so any stimulus at this
point is good i'm actually quite
intrigued i mean obviously we don't yet
know the full details of the trade
policy fiscal policy and infrastructure
regulation but least i think the
direction of travel is right and what we
need to be clear about is we may be
generally right but specifically wrong
and that's the challenge here is what
the specifics will really make a
difference yeah and Bob is there a
concern that actually the specifics need
you be much stronger than what President
rob has delivered because a lot is
already priced in the market yes I I
think Francine a couple of things first
of all the banks are doing extremely
well right now as you've pointed out
with higher interest rates I think
they're anticipating some roll back in
the dodd-frank thing where you know they
can actually go out and start doing some
things relative to mortgages as opposed
to this phantom banking system that
we've seen developed over the last
couple of years so I think that's very
strong I think yellen's comments about
interest rate increase again is a very
positive sign one strengthen the economy
to again you've seen the impact on the
bank's Tom so I think that's a very good
thing we're getting the usual dose of
nardelie optimism Hughes straighten him
out okay please help me here with the
fact i've got a run rate of u.s. gdp of
1.9 percent where's the growth when's
the growth well i think it did there
isn't it may be enough growth but we
could be knocking between you know three
to four percent gdp growth globally this
year and certainly I would hope we could
potentially be near the upper end but to
be honest the interest rate out
environment really makes a huge
difference I mean if you price in the
the dot plots you get a fifteen to
thirty percent increase in bank earnings
now we've already had the bank sector
rally over twenty percent so I think it
needs to come from either higher
activity and therefore higher growth as
you say Tom or also a much stronger
sense the change in the reg latoria
gender makes a difference and you
obviously got to rule o coming on next I
think he's not gonna be talking about
rolling bag but simply the ratchet
stopping makes a difference because the
rules today for a bank is five percent
leverage ratio they were arguing for ten
that at least not you know I think just
simply standing still gives the bank's
more confidence that they can work
through their issues so why are we not
actually talking about a trade war why
is the market completely ignoring the
fact that we could see tariffs that up
and this is what he prompts in campaign
trail so far he's delivered everything
he said that campaign trail I'm really
struck with this because I think what we
haven't yet fleshed out is what does
economic nationalism really mean in
practice and I'm completely with you
Francine I really want to understand
what does that mean for the region ship
not just with Mexico but with China with
India and obviously China is the
epicenter of the discussion
and they're already a huge number of
disputes of the WTO but whether he
accelerates that yeah really a big
concern I think at this stage though the
markets assuming the checks and balances
will ease off the worst of the excesses
we don't yet know